buonasera grazie del dito 7 11 giovani
del sud e innovazione oltre che
chiaramente l'imprenditorialità ho
scritto questi appunti davvero degli
appunti foglio in viaggio da dove solo
nella serie di altre esperienze della
croce mentre le terze sono sono gli
alfieri che correvano le caratteristiche
devono essere qualche modo messo in
evidenza questa nostra cominciare e in
così poco tempo ho deciso di cominciare
dal punto di vista di mia nonna
ho saputo che qualche dei parenti vanno
forte mia nonna adriana era di milano e
lei amava il sud per un po gli venivano
i nervi perché pensava che la
caratteristica del sud che fosse un
posto pieno di persone il lievito le
chiamava lei cioè di persone molto
contagiose molto attive ma che in
qualche modo avevano la caratteristica
di annullarsi l'un l'altro diceva voi
del sud
avete bisogno di farina da far crescere
qui giù e tutto lievito non si riesce a
mangiare non succede niente
quando penso alla scommessa che noi
abbiamo facendo questa avventura del
programma sulle politiche giovanili
bollenti spiriti
beh penso che noi cerchiamo di lavorare
con le persone lievito per farle
crescere e per far crescere questo posto
qua senza bisogno di andare cercando
farina da qualche altra parte
ma di quale tipo di persone stiamo
parlando chi sono gli innovatori con cui
noi lavoriamo e soprattutto che ci
faccio io che non mi occupo
specificatamente di innovazione allora
io ho invitato queste persone
queste persone sono degli innovatori
ma l'uso degli innovatori che lavorano
nei laboratori non sono degli innovatori
che smanettano sul web sono delle
persone che come dire occupano un
pattinodromo a mesagne in provincia di
brindisi che oggi è diventata un'impresa
culturale sono delle esperienze che noi
abbiamo sostenuto con con una cosa che
si chiama principi attivi
ci tengo a sottolinearlo è una foto che
mi piace molto perché penso che la
scommessa che noi stiamo giocando sia
quella di ragionare di una forma di
innovazione distribuita si parla molto
di intelligenza distribuita di
intelligenza connettiva possiamo
immaginare tantissime persone giovani
impegnati a cercare di cambiare il mondo
anche senza necessariamente accedere al
grandi scenari globali anche pensando di
poter cambiare il contesto che hanno
intorno
ecco noi pensiamo che una delle
importanti scommesse dell'innovazione e
che può giocare una politica pubblica
sia quelli di aiutare le persone a
cambiare la realtà che li circonda
con quali strumenti si può raggiungere
un risultato di questo genere oppure la
potremmo dire così come si fa a far
emergere le forze latenti me la pensiamo
in questo modo non esiste innovazione e
imprenditorialità
se non c'è una tradizione di di
attivazione della tua esperienza di vita
cioè importante che tu sia abituato a
fare cose presto da subito per questo
sosteniamo con i sistemi più anti
burocratici possibili più immediati più
di più più diretti delle esperienze di
persone giovani che si mettono insieme
per fare delle cose
questo cercando di generare degli
effetti su grande scala
la parte collettiva dell'attivazione e
la mobilitazione
noi pensiamo che il modo migliore per
far emergere i talenti che non si vedono
sia quello di farli muovere tutti
insieme e pensiamo anche che i soldi
pubblici che hanno un rapporto
problematico con l'innovazione anche con
l'imprenditorialità possono essere un
aiuto possono anche essere un diserbante
la creatività no beh noi pensiamo però
che usati bene in un certo modo possono
generare una grande mobilitazione
collettiva
pensate in questo momento esistono 2343
gruppi di giovani pugliesi che in ogni
angolo di questa regione dal quasi 100
per cento dei comuni hanno immaginato
qualche cosa per migliorare la propria
vita e la vita del contesto in cui in
cui in cui vivono e siamo impegnati a
selezionarli immaginate che gigantesca
forza di cambiamento sia questo è
l'istituzione che cosa fa in un contesto
del genere qual è il ruolo che si può
immaginare però non ha un ente pubblico
mi ha molto colpito la cosa che sentivo
prima le grandi innovazioni che nascono
dalla tecnologia e le istituzioni che
corte che rincorrono lente e
immaginabile un ruolo di un'istituzione
che non si limita soltanto ad aspettare
che le cose succedano di farsi tirare da
tutte le parti per dire accorgi che
qualcosa sta cambiando è possibile
immaginare che l'istituzione possa
essere un protagonista di un processo di
cambiamento
noi pensiamo questo una delle cose più
preziose che un'istituzione può fare è
far incontrare le persone
vi ricordate quel video che girava su
internet un grande successo come nascono
le buone idee che alla fine ci portava
delle conclusioni abbastanza ovvie le
idee nascono perché si accendono l'un
l'altra come le scintille lettere che
diceva engels parecchi
anni fa ebbene perché l'istituzione non
lavora mai per mettere in relazione le
persone con cui interloquisce se ci
pensate se il vero problema è l'incontro
delle persone le istituzioni potrebbero
essere degli hub fenomenali questa cosa
però non lo fa quasi nessuno
noi stiamo provando a farla sia sulla
rete e sia promuovendo opportunità di
incontro faccia a faccia e come sono
andate queste cose come sta andando come
funziona questo processo di attivazione
e anche di mobilitazione collettiva che
risultati sta raggiungendo beh
rassicurano stupito l'auditorio ci sono
le start up generando forme di
attivazione diffusa sollecitando le
persone giovani di questa regione a
pensare a provare a sperimentare e anche
a sbagliare escono fuori i talenti
escono fuori le eccellenze sono quelle
che si presentano le piece competition
che magari li vincono a livello
nazionale a volte anche livello
internazionale sono protagonisti
dell'innovazione sono gli innovatori
come noi siamo abituati ad immaginarli
però proviamo a fare un ragionamento di
ingegneria inversa del talento che
proviamo a osservare queste persone e
chiederci come si sono trovate che
percorso hanno fatto come mai sono
arrivate come dire a essere persone che
chiudono il round con un seed capital
piuttosto che vincono il forum sulle
start up innovative di livello
internazionale
ebbene osservando le loro storie ci
rendiamo conto che quasi mai la loro
traiettoria
come dire è stata sostenuta dal sistema
che hanno intorno quasi mai il sistema
di riconoscimento della qualità ha
funzionato
spesso hanno avuto bisogno di un
sostegno in quella particolare fase in
cui sei tra 0 e 1 in cui hai bisogno di
un finanziamento ma forse è bisogno
soprattutto di un incoraggiante
e questa esperienza non è altro che un
sistema una specie di prova tecnica di
costruzione di un ecosistema e noi lo
sappiamo che un ecosistema è fatto di
tante cose
la nostra foresta pluviale fatta di
tante cose e noi per il mestiere che
facciamo ci occupiamo della dimensione
immateriale ci occupiamo della
dimensione culturale
pensate che impatto ha sui ragazzi di
questa regione sapere che due persone di
25 di 27 anni è tornati da delle
carriere importanti all'estero tornano
qui fondono una società e costruiscono
la ferrari dell'area il più veloce
biposto in carbonio del mondo della sua
categoria e lo vendono in 15 paesi e in
che modo noi possiamo essere ab e
mettere in contatto questa storia con
una generazione di sperimentatori noi lo
sappiamo che stiamo lavorando sulla
dimensione immateriale culturale sulla
dimensione software e che l'ecosistema
dell'innovazione fatto anche di altre
cose è fatto anche di leggi fatte anche
di finanziamenti regole però noi
sappiamo anche che se l'innovazione non
è sostenuta da un grande cambiamento
culturale probabilmente non avrà non
avrà successo è l'ultima cosa che che
voglio raccontarvi è questa esperienza
che si chiama laboratori dal basso e che
il tentativo di prendere tutto ciò che
le persone giovani di questa regione
sanno di metterlo insieme e di aiutarli
a chiamare le migliori teste a
insegnargli cose ci sono due immagini e
con questo chiudo
sopra c'è un'aula dell'università di
bari piena di ragazzi che stanno
seguendo una lezione ma senza un corso
universitario senza dei crediti
formativi
senza un esame da fare semplicemente
perché hanno loro scelto di invitare un
relatore e sotto c'è un'immagine della
più antica università del mondo
occidentale nel dodicesimo secolo era
composta da un consorzio di studenti che
chiamava gli innovatori dell'epoca a
insegnargli nel meglio che c'era e
pensiamo che questa possa essere una
strada molto interessante per continuare
il lavoro che abbiamo iniziato grazie